[موسيقى]
أعتقد أن فكرة السيارات بدون سائق كانت
موجودة منذ أن أصبحت السيارات
شائعة في اليمين الأمريكي بالتأكيد
منذ الثلاثينيات من القرن الماضي، كان
فيلمي المفضل عندما كنت أكبر
هو Herbie the Love Bug،
حيث توجد سيارة فولكس فاجن هذه التي تعد
في الأساس كيانًا واعيًا للقيادة الذاتية
في  سيارة إنها
أطرف شيء شوهد على العجلات على الإطلاق،
عد إلى المعرض العالمي الرابع والستين وكان لديك
شركات تتحدث عن السيارات ذاتية القيادة
مع شخص ما في برج المراقبة يتحدث
إليك عن الأمر، حسنًا، ارفع يديك
عن عجلة القيادة الآن وسنفعل ذلك.  سوف
آخذك إلى المنزل، لقد كانت هذه الفكرة موجودة
لأنه يبدو من الواضح جدًا أن
السيارة
تتحرك ذاتيًا بشكل جيد، ويجب أن تكون
سيارة بالكامل وتقود نفسها.
يموت حوالي 46000 شخص سنويًا في حوادث
السيارات، والسيارات ذاتية القيادة إذا
أصبحت موجودة في كل مكان
ستقضي فعليًا على ذلك  التفكير هو أن
غالبية حوادث الاصطدام ناتجة عن
خطأ بشري بين علامتي الاقتباس، فإننا سنقضي على
البشر، وسنزيل الأخطاء
ولكن دعونا نواجه الأمر عندما تظهر السيارات ذاتية القيادة
في الأخبار، فهي في الأخبار
لإفسادها هاو أوه أوه لا
نحن  نحن نسير على الجانب الخطأ من
الطريق، لذا فإن التحدي هو أن لدينا
آلات تتفاعل مع الناس،
والقيادة الذاتية هي أحد الأسباب التي تجعل
الناس يعملون بجد على
الذكاء الاصطناعي، كما تعلمون، إن
الحفاظ على الأرض شيء واحد  الطريق السريع ولكن في
الواقع أن تحب القيادة بشكل كامل يتطلب قدرة تشبه قدرة
الإنسان تقريبًا على الارتجال
في السنوات التي كنت أغطي فيها هذه
الصناعة، السيارات ذاتية القيادة بالكامل
دائمًا ما تكون على بعد عامين وستظل على
بعد عامين
الآن عندما يتعلق الأمر بذلك، لن يكون الأمر كذلك
في وقت واحد، على سبيل المثال، نرى بالفعل
أشياء مثل الزراعة باستخدام
الجرارات ذاتية القيادة، حيث يمكن للمزارعين الخروج إلى
هناك وبرمجة الآلة للعودة إلى المنزل وتناول
وجبة الإفطار في جميع أنحاء المزرعة
بينما يتم حرث الحقل بواسطة
جرار مستقل،
وهذا يحمل وعدًا بـ  إضفاء الطابع الديمقراطي على
السيارات، ليس من الضروري أن يكون لديك رخصة
قيادة، ليس من الضروري أن تعرف
كيفية القيادة عندما يصل العالم إلى
نقطة يمكن فيها للأم أو الأب أن يصطحبا
طفلهما في مرحلة الروضة إلى السيارة
ويقولان هنا يا بني، احصل على  في هذه السيارة
ستأخذك إلى المدرسة لأنه
شيء واحد بالنسبة لي أن أركب سيارة بدون سائق
وأن أكون على استعداد لتحمل هذه المخاطرة
عندما أتمكن من وضع طفل صغير في تلك السيارة،
فهذا هو الاختبار النهائي
[موسيقى] [
موسيقى]
أجنبي